[Music]
this is Major I'm on site I'm going in
hi I'm Maximo from FX guide.com for
Wired this time we're looking at the
brilliant visual effects from MPC in the
film ghost in the shell
the film opens with the shelling
sequence which pays a march to the 1995
anime opening in which we see the
creation of a cyborg later revealed to
be major this was created using a blend
of computer graphics and practical
animatronics from where to workshop
well MPC referenced the live-action in
the end to get this really detailed
skeleton with muscles it's fully skin
that is major the majority the shots
ended up being digital the sequence was
fully previous then almost every shot
was filmed as live-action
but it's testament to MPC and the
approach of director Rupert Sanders that
this opening sequence is so realistic
and yet in the end about 70% of the
sequence is in fact fully digital now
this allowed for more backlighting
scattering as well as having slightly
more complex camera moves the production
design in this film is remarkable and
it's not just major the benefits from
this from the evil spider tank to the
assassin geisha bot there's a host of
characters and complex visual effects
work the production VFX of advisors with
Guillaume Roshan and John Dykstra NPCs
team worked really closely not only to
match that production design and
incorporate all of the digital versions
of weatr workshops props where needed
but also to match the complex lighting
on set major has a special bodysuit that
allows for invisibility but it required
a glimmering effect even when it's not
transparent and bc had to roto the suit
and in many shots remove wires and rigs
so it's decided that Scarlett
Johansson's suit that she wears would
actually be fully digitally replaced
throughout the film
[Music]
in fact apart from two shots every time
you see the white suit it's entirely CG
the only two practical suit shots in the
whole film are in fact her out of focus
and close to camera replacing the suit
was particularly complex in this
sequence where major suit and the
invisibility effect are shown in this
really complex water fight sequence
[Music]
these shots also highlight the
futuristic city that NPC had to build
and it's holographic signage ghost in
the shell' was shot in the streets of
New Zealand but the team only had to do
set extensions but also populate the
world with futuristic signage both these
signs and the other Holograms that are
in the film were created using a large
number of cameras in one of two
different special camera arrays for the
deep dive sequence the team used 150
digital stills cameras but for the solid
Holograms or Saleh grams
they used 82d computer vision cameras
recording moving footage the deep dive
had 27 characters but the team also
filmed 50 to 60 actors to be used in the
Holograms
the idea of the photogrammetry solved
having to model Textron animate all of
these characters but the approach
basically used photogrammetry on each
frame so in total there was some 30 mm
3d scans the voxel grid that we actually
see on-screen was lower resolution in
the poorer neighborhoods making the
science seem older and much higher
resolution in the wealthier parts of
town but this approach has no
correspondence between frames each frame
is a new 3d model as these per frame
model sequences of high resolution point
clouds are fed into the voxel grid it
distributes them in these effectively
small boxes what we see on film are
these different boxes being lit up by
the average colour of the points inside
them the output from this Houdini
software is a lego style 3d model that
the team can now relight and also cast
bounce light onto if you look carefully
some of the solid grams light up
buildings near them but some of them are
also are themselves lit by street lights
cars and other signage NPCs R&D team
developed completely new software that
allowed them to reconstruct process
manipulate and deal with this huge
amount of volumetric data and place it
into these shots well don't forget
please subscribe for more behind the
scenes action i'm mike seymour for wide
find out who I was
everything they told you was a lie who
are you they did not save your life they
stole it